in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help some ml video experts with
their download speeds will we hit the
target bitrate stay tuned to find out
video miner is a video processing and ml
company and they came to me with an
issue it was taking about two minutes to
transfer a video from cloud storage to a
VM where computation could occur now 120
seconds may not sound like a long time
to transfer a four gig video but when
you're paying for the CPU while that's
downloading it feels like an eternity
worse off is that one of their engineers
was reporting that curl was
outperforming gsutil for the Downloads
which didn't sound right to me
so of course I wanted to see the problem
myself so I set up a small test that
downloaded videos of different sizes
from a cloud storage bucket to a VM in
u.s. central one and actually confirmed
their performance findings asking around
it seemed as though the challenge with
gsutil
is that the default settings don't line
up well for large file downloads by
default gsutil were spread downloads
across four threads but only use one
process for copying a single file on a
powerful VM we can improve that
performance by limiting the number of
threads forcing the system to use
multiple processes instead to do this we
can specify a command line option to
reduce the thread count to one now with
this small change we improve the
performance but we're still not at the
level that curl is showing when fetching
through HTTP so for large files there is
a nifty feature in GS util that should
help us out a bit more GS util uses HTTP
range get requests to perform sliced
downloads in parallel when downloading
large objects from Google Cloud Storage
along with setting the thread count to 1
we will also set the number of Max
components to 8 this gives us a much
improved for download speed so if you're
interested in using either of these
flags to improve performance check out
the article linked in the description
below and don't forget to check out the
rest of cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts